well now returning to our top story the
earthquake in Morocco let's now speak to
Al jazeera's Omar alhaj he's in
Marrakesh Omar can you talk us through
what you're seeing there around you
Yes actually we are in one of places
where people decided to spend their
nights uh here in maracasia frieden of
another uh uh earthquake and also we are
waiting for new numbers updated numbers
by the uh officials regarding the recent
uh uh casualties uh and death toll
actually the numbers are as you know was
doubled during the past three or four
hours we were talking about more uh
we're talking about 1400s of uh 48 1400s
did and now we are talking about more
than 2 000 also there's uh more than 1
400 Serious injury that might rise the
number of the death toll in this
catastrophe regarding the rescue
operations actually the the teams the
local teams and also the foreigns who
arrived during the the past couple of
hours are literally fighting tooth and
nail but again and there's some uh
obstacles they they face and then first
of all the disadvantages of the the the
geographic nature of the police is that
was uh hit by that large-scale uh
earthquake behind me if we can show the
these people a group of people actually
who decide to spend the whole night
actually the numbers were in in hundreds
during the uh uh the past couple hours
but uh I can say that people cannot
stand uh uh the weather especially
during uh during the night was freezing
literally he so they decided to find a
shelter and governmental institutes and
people are seeking for uh shelters in in
the house of their uh relatives today
also as you as you know the the the
national morning was uh declared by the
authorities and the flags all over the
country where uh uh lowered again the uh
the government said that they are doing
their best but again uh and I was
talking about the all these efforts made
by rescue teams but like two hours one
hour ago there was some calling from
people in different places and different
Villages and countries said that no one
reached them from the the beginning of
this catastrophe and that again because
of the because of the the far away
places and all all these Village uh
based on high hills and mountains around
Maracas and the south of Morocco Al
jazeera's Uma al-hajj there with the
latest for us from the ground in
Marrakech thank you Irma will be having
ongoing coverage from across Morocco
here on Al Jazeera